which doesn't belong and why let's begin
with refrigerator perry from
wrestlemania 2.
uh lawrence taylor from wrestlemania 11
rob gronkowski 33 and 36 which doesn't
belong and why
i mean i would have to say the fridge
um because to me
if if if i want to get if i want guys
who are really going to be
dangerous in the ring for some reason i
i don't view the fridge as being
particularly dangerous in the ring
however i would fear rob gronkowski
i say the fridge doesn't belong because
for me
no one ever burned his bright beyond
the sports world than william the
refrigerator perry the phenomenon that
he was in 1985. i remember it vividly
and it's never been matched by anyone
else and one of the most unlikely of
guys that would have become that point
for so much notoriety as part of the
1985 bears so uh the refrigerator
getting it done now mike can i can i
tell you a very quick story can i tell
you a quick story about that
the day after the super bowl that the
fridge scored the touchdown and walter
payton didn't
that's when i knew that there was
something strange inside the chicago
bears
because that was not a happy team
you know they killed the patriots in the
super bowl but it wasn't a happy team
and it everybody's always said it's so
amazing
that that they they only won one super
bowl and yeah it probably is they're
very talented but i just think there was
just
too much internal crap
on that bears team and in that franchise
the defensive coordinator versus the
head coach
you know fridge getting to score one of
the greatest players of all time not it
just it felt really weird the day after
that game
i love the richard dentline we won a
super bowl because of mike ditka and we
won a super bowl because of mike ditka
because yeah that's a team that they
expected to win multiple championships
all right which doesn't belong in y tom
brady quarterback whisperers charlie
weiss josh mcdaniels bruce arians which
doesn't belong and why
wow that's a really good question i
would say uh i think they all belong but
if anybody doesn't belong i would say
it's bruce arians because tom brady was
who he was
when he got to tampa
and part of who he was was birthed by
uh charlie weiss and uh and josh
mcdaniels
jose weiss doesn't belong because i mean
look he never was an nfl head coach
sometimes these are extremely
superficial and simple and i don't have
any other ideas so i'll just say weiss
because he wasn't an nfl head coach the
other two became nfl head coaches and
aryans obviously a super bowl winner cam
newton jameis winston andy dalton which
doesn't belong and why all three
quarterbacks on one year prove it
deals uh i would say cam newton doesn't
belong because while the other two
i could see the other two
making a second year
in in each of their places i can't see
cam newton being the quarterback of the
patriots in 2022
yeah i say winston doesn't belong
because he's the only one that i really
don't know whether or not he's going to
be the week one starter at this point
there's going to be a competition he's
going to have to earn it i think taysom
hill has the upper hand dalton we can
call the starter barring something
unforeseen in chicago newton the starter
barring something unforeseen in new
england all right new general managers
drafting in the top 10
three weeks from yesterday brad holmes
of the lions scott federer of the
panthers george payton of the broncos
which doesn't belong and why
well i'd say right now that uh george
payton doesn't belong because i think
that george payton is in
the worst position of the three general
managers in that the other two i think
still could have the power to move
around either up or down not that george
payton doesn't have that power
but the two guys ahead of them at four
and eight have are going to have more
influence at the top of the draft than
george payton picking knight
and peyton is the guy among the three
who really doesn't have a quarterback
solution even though the lions could
take one at seven they've got jared goff
the panthers now have sam darnold all
they can theory can take one at eight
and fitter hasn't ruled that out peyton
it just feels like it's an open slate
still for the broncos and it feels like
there isn't satisfaction with drew lock
a second round from a couple of years
ago
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports